après quatre ans de relation l'acteur de
47 ans et léna 74 ans comme tous les
beaux gosses et bien se sépare de sa
nouvelle copine c'est pas la première
fois qu'ils quittent une fille de 25 ans
regardez le mag on a vraiment
l'impression que d'éclat filles les
atteint merci au revoir par contre a
terminé à l'eau si
les sur rail août à saint-tropez que
l'acteur américain leonardo dicaprio
aurait été aperçu cet été au bras de sa
nouvelle compagne
dans une étudiante de 22 ans d'origine
ukrainienne qui se prénommerait maria
bérigaud va et l'acteur de titanic son
bien être resté bloqué 25 ans en arrière
à l'époque de sa rencontre avec kate
winslet alias rose
y regarder de plus près si toutes ces ex
ont pour point commun d'être mannequin
aucune ne dépasse la fatidique des 25
ans
camila morin à nina agdal bar rafaeli
leonardo dicaprio avons fêté ses 48 ans
en novembre prochain l'écart d'âge avec
chacune de ses conquêtes ne les prépas à
part bonjour on veut un bissau
oui et si notre léonardois sur mon père
de délire sectaire incidence a beaucoup
amusé des internautes comment leonardo
dicaprio voit les femmes quand elles
dépassent 25 ans courage à la jeune
maria qui n'a donc plus que trois ans
avant de passer la fameuse date de
péremption
[Musique]
on a de la plaquette que choquer qu'à
choquer choquette a choqué florian ont
réagi on se rappelle un petit peu non ça
c'est oui non florian hewitt journaliste
choquait pas chaud qui est choqué alors
on a déchanté partie je suis un petit
peu te des sautés pourquoi parce que
t'as 40 2 tu sens que
j'aurais jamais une charge pour cette
façon avec leonardo dicaprio non mais
moi ce qui me choque en fait c'est que
ce vieux beau de 47 pige aujourd'hui
dans six attaques cas des jeunes filles
qui étaient même pas nés quand il avait
fait titanic on sent qu'il ya une sorte
de mode opératoire d'une dot de
quelqu'un qui aime bien avoir des
relations souvent prises avec ses il
faut que ce soit non mais bien sûr que
oui on choisit des jeunes en général et
pour l'heure leur candeur parce qu'elles
sont naïves parce qu'elles sont choisis
pas des puits qui avait rien et choisit
juste eu de bonnes choses ça devient
millionnaire ou bien même elles sont
douzièmes et il les choisit parce qu'il
sait qu'elles vont être malléable et ça
pour moi c'est vraiment un bateau 25 à
25 ans à 25 ans n'hésitez pas malléable
sait pas quand il a procédé à 25 ans ou
24 ans tu sais très bien ce que tu fais
sont intelligentes et elle ce cas pas
vieille amado faire elle se tape un beau
gosse un beau gosse richissime
charismatique grands acteurs elles sont
toutes aussi chanceuse que lui est
chanceux d'avoir des petits jeunes
chacune des chaînes de balles 25 ans
avec moi c'est parce qu'il a mené des
missions comme si j'allais ya plein de
deux dames qui m alors on s'engueule
soir dans l'autre sens yeux on savait
pas lequel viseur ouais rien elle est la
muse départager les ça ne fait pas
lâcher oui maintenant jean pascal elle
dégage pas tous les mecs dès qu'ils
atteignent 110 apparent vie dégage pas
réalise avec de s'échapper il fait pas
de mal avait pas mal est fait de mal à
personne oui il a bien raison t'imagines
changer comme ça que des jeunes est tout
le temps là et le virer ce mec il a une
vie rêvée on est tous d'accord ils sont
tous les mêmes gars de the guardian mais
qu'il regarde ça qu'elle il a du pognon
et chant olemps laquelle vie
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai quoi alors non non mais il
affiche petit névrose maintenance en
train de naître les filles abandonnées
la parole tu es à ludivine les grilles
tu as 22 ans dicaprio ta bile sur son
yacht mais pas trois ans avec silva ou
pas mais bien sûr mais
enfin les jeunes femmes qu'il faut
assurer pas mes mots puissants qui ont
de l'argent et qu'ils sont super célèbre
c'est ça vient pas des jeunes le
problème ça vient de lui c'est
symptomatique d'un pervers pas au nom
mais c'est la version que de vouloir que
des jeunes filles de potes quatre ans et
dès lors que la date de péremption
arrive on les a guidés pour nous et j'ai
bien aimé les filles vous avez 4s après
vingt-cinq aussi je sais pas quoi vous
dire
attention slovaques ont tiré des balles
de cellex c vous paierez mais une
d'abord qui a un petit peu plus de 25
mais pas trop il a d'abord
j'ai eu et j'ai été super comme estime
s'est passé lors ans
bah oui mme sima connu il ya 30 ans pas
sexuels l'abandon du g2a machin était
très jolie voix la nouvelle de cet aveux
spontanés oh ouais moi j'aime leonardo
dicaprio c'est tout ce que j'exècre
tellement ils m'auraient invité sur son
yacht mais j'aurais dit non je trouve
sain mais ne pas appeler
si on lui fait un petit moment et un
jour t'inquiète pas la vivace en château
tas d'anecdotes jour inscrits à une
anecdote mis à jour à tata tata non mais
parce que le mandat d'abbas est là mais
c'est moi non mais c'est quoi la cisa
une anecdote c'est le public l'aveu chez
eux là sur quoi les roms
riche mais plus beau que dicaprio ah ça
c'est vrai
merci de nous ramener dans le débat
comparez de leonardo dicaprio qui décrit
sa copine à 25 ans il a 20 21 24 ans 25
ans il arrête alors vous savez que
médicalement est ce que vous dites est
vrai il paraît que médicalement à partir
de 25 ans c'est le moment où le corps
brûle plus de cellules qu'il n'en crée
donc et finalement on commence à
vieillir alors la chute et martin weale
à witham mais on commence à vieillir à
partir de 25 ans peut-être qu'il est
hyper dans le médical n'apporterait donc
et les jambes ça choquait bas les aigris
comme ludivine que sont pas montés sur
le bateau dans le médical et moi jouer
isabelle avait une anecdote parce qu'il
l'a rencontré et j'ai une autre anecdote
aussi pour vous parce que ayem a passé
une soirée avec dicaprio comme toujours
côté losail côté des beaux garçons non
et elle connaît un put si tu connais sa
nouvelle copine alors le débat vers
keesing du teasing du teasing d'abord le
plus gros teaser c'est quoi c'est
l'anecdote d'isabelle et du kpayo 30
secondes ça serait dans un bain de foule
rouge comprise aux jeunes vous citerai
pas ça cette embauche comprise un coin
de france que je ne citerai pas il était
à une table et moi je regardais les gens
que cette table et j'ai eu quand même
une bonne vue encore et je me suis dit
tiens il ya un mec là il avait l'air
d'un petit cochon est gelée absolument
pas reconnu se trouver sexy avachi
trouver qui faisait donc c'était
absolument pas admirative on m'a dit tu
vas pas lui demander un autographe c'est
di caprio je me suis dit [ __ ] voilà
pourquoi t'es pas activement j'aime bien
de leur monde et ça les anecdotes de sa
vie c'est pour ça je me dis
je peux dire quelque chose les
foules à vous dire j'étais bien au pire
pour repenser public aucun vandalisme
on a vendu du rêve aux gens
non non c'est bien qu'on sache qui ne
fait pas rêver va peut-être toi parce
que moi je peux dire que je peux dire
quelques moi aussi je viens de dire que
tu as couché j'ai une anecdote non j'ai
pas couché avec lui malheureusement mais
à on a vu sur malheureusement son
tableau de chasse impressionnant on
pourrait même rajouter j j a dit parce
qu'en ce moment on parle beaucoup d'une
rumeur en truck est en train de naître
il a il a très très très mauvaise
réputation dans le milieu people en tout
cas en france c'est à dire les
journalistes photographes etc on sait
qu'il a mauvaise réputation un jour j'ai
parlé avec un célèbre photographe
paparazzi etc qui sait beaucoup de
choses et il m'a dit un jour je parlerai
en parlant caprio
je t'aime en face et ces rumeurs sur la
rumeur sur rumeur un peu d'huile à
hambye il a envie de sortir avec de la
chair fraîche ça lui plaît de la chair
fraîche et oui pour moi
pourquoi ils sont pour aussi à paramé
bien sûr non mais sérieusement pour que
ludivine tu ne décrédibilise les fils on
a l'impression que les titres sont
victimes de ce double dont 2007 à moins
débile elles peuvent avoir envie elles
peuvent désirer le et bien sûr qu'ils
vont en connaissances et le fameux
l'euthanasie je pense que par l'ol qui
était une année en thaïlande ans et qui
s'était planqué il avait réservé une
suite en thaïlande dicaprio à bateaux
venant magnifique but en thaïlande et il
me dit y avait douze jeunes filles dans
la suite mais attention toutes majeures
vaccinés qui savaient pourquoi elle
était là oui les forces para et des
machins bien défendre il n'y a que deux
il
est bon
peru que c'est la 13e
[Applaudissements]
as tu peur at elle dit
alors attention maintenant attention là
elle a non seulement rencontré dicaprio
plus d'enfants boîte de nuit mais
connaît parfaitement sa nouvelle copine
qui s'appelle bahia bérégovoy merci
beaucoup alors dit nous sommes bons
alors déjà petite parenthèse on est en
train de le pointer du doigt mais ça me
fait doucement rire cette hypocrisie
pasquin a plus d'un qui le fait et on
n'en parle pas mais au moins ils
l'assument c'est une question goût il a
mené jeune femme chacun sait bin moi
j'aime les hommes plus âgés chacun ses
goûts la petite convoi alors moi ça me
fait vraiment bizarre parce que j'ai vu
grandir il s'avère que c'est la
meilleure amie de mon ex belle fille si
belles choses sur ouï dire la fille de
vincent nickelés assez bas non c'est sa
meilleure amie donc j'ai vu grandir ça
me fait très bizarre de la voir là il
faut savoir que cette jeune femme dont
on ne parlera pas du tout besoin
d'argent l'argent m'abonne ne va pas
être un homme riche en six ans que je
connais personnellement et que j'aime
beaucoup elle n'a jamais eu besoin de
rien elle a toujours été pourri gâté par
ses parents je pense qu'à une réelle
histoire d'amour elle a toujours aussi
eu ce petit truc de mais les gars sont
un peu plus âgés et à la javel mais la
manne doit avoir un gâchis quand deux
ans et c'est que dans deux ans elle est
dans le coup mais bon j'ai envie de te
dire je pense qu'elle a eu son coup de
coeur elle l'a vécue et puis voilà en
tout cas le fait pas pour l'argent est
le fait pas par intérêt l'a toujours eu
une vie extraordinaire ses parents on
pouvait gâtés je pense qu'il ya vraiment
une histoire d'amour après cc gundam 2
je l'aï croisé plusieurs fois non pas en
boîte de nuit j'ai croisé à l'amfar et à
la soirée de grisogono à l'amfar et à la
soirée de grisogono par le festival de
cannes a brûlé une présence voilà où il
était présent au qui n'ont le garçon
très coquine ou des sourires way très
coquine ou tu as fait quoi j'étais un
peu trop bien j'avais 27 ans
[Applaudissements]
je ne savais pas là d'une voix il a été
a priori on fait un peu sourire tu
refais pas été accompagnée de monsieur
mikli j'étais en couple je oui mais ni
clément je crois - risque de dire oui
mais je l'aimé beaucoup oui non mais qu
harry caine amour
par les amours petite exclu tu parles
tatouage tout à l'heure personne ne le
sait mais je tatouage les initiales du
pavage mon fils et je n'ai jamais
regretté voilà c'est un vrai nom voiture
blanche avec une bonne quand même pas
parce qu'on n'est plus ensemble oui
c'est vrai bien sûr je comprends tu veux
dire quelque chose je voulais juste
préciser que l'amfar dont parle ayem
c'est le dîner de charité de gala d'une
des soirées les plus prisées aux
féculents cannes voilà les gens qui nous
regardent qui savent pas forcément
réalité des bons même pour ce qui
regarde moi j' avais aucune idée je
t'avouerai qu'il mange je vois la soirée
très importante c'est vrai à l'éliminer
non